here now judge jeanine pirro fox news
contributor leo 2.0 terrell
uh judge i'm impressed uh i don't know i
don't want to lose you to hollywood
judge we can't lose your voice
academy award academy award oscar oscar
okay well have we all had the have we
all had this
the shared experience you go to a
baseball game basketball game hockey
game
boxing match i've been to all of them
major league baseball
and all of a sudden everyone you're
talking to strangers you're talking
about the pitching
you're high-fiving after a glance grand
slam or a slam
dunk or uh you know a long
touchdown pass or a touchdown run and
your team goes ahead
i've done it why are we going to add
politics to this
judge well first of all it's a mistake
and by the way i'm not being blacklisted
i don't know where you got that from but
i i think the problem right now is that
everyone is trying to make america into
something that she isn't
and unfortunately you know sports is the
one thing that gives us as you said the
ability to
have some free time make friends be part
of something
together in this revisionist history
with with the united states asking the
u.n to come into america and assess
whether or not we're a racist country
i'm telling you sean where that's going
is they're going to finally say that we
need to pay reparations
and that's where this is all going they
are destroying everything that is
american
and the nfl if they want to do something
if they want to play two anthems
or whatever but you know if you want to
change things in america you don't do it
with a song
you do it by effectuating change in in
courts in the legislature with people in
power in schools
on the school board which by the way is
what god's not that is all about it's
about parents fighting for the fact
that their children are being taught
things like critical race theory
that have nothing to do with their
belief in god and their but their
freedom of speech
and that's why we've got to keep
fighting and that's what god's not said
of us about
now that they've added politics leo i
don't think it's by accident
mlb mba nfl
ratings and in some cases down
dramatically
people are saying they want no part of
this that's not
we we love the sport we love this we
don't want to be lectured to during
sports
uh i don't i think they're doing great
damage to their leagues
oh i think they're doing great damage
but there is it's called appeasement
they're appeasing the extreme group
black lives matter who speaks for no one
who represents no one and i'll tell you
right now
and respectfully they can't win in a
court of law they can't win their
policies do not
call for working within the system they
want to destroy the system that's why
they're trying to destroy our schools
they're in the streets they're crying
and the democrats has adopted them as
part of their group
they're a fringe group and when they try
to talk about racial equity
that gets torn apart in court all these
pro-preferential treatment based on race
programs have been knocked down in court
what we have is sports
organizations are afraid of these groups
so they get shaken down
and that's why you have this black
national anthem in conclusion there's
only one national anthem
there's only one american flag nothing
else nothing more
politics should not be in sports and
judge by the way it was
antonio sabato jr he that said that he
was blacklisted by
traditional hollywood just to be clear
for you not your movie in particular
i want to see you on the big screen i
can't wait
go to godsnotdead.com okay i will right
after the show
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else